today I want to discuss the real reason
why you should start consuming liver
liver is the number one nutrient dense
food on planet Earth number two would be
oysters but number one is liver and it's
not just the nutrients that liver will
give you there's something else that
liver will do or a great majority of the
population and so hear me out because at
least half of you watching has this very
specific problem that you can benefit
greatly from consuming more liver now
you might already know that liver has
the best bioavailable nutrients like
vitamin A and it has it on a vitamin n
it has B1 B2 B3 B6 B9 which is folate
we'll come back to that in a second
B12 choline that has vitamin D it has
iron the heme form of iron which is very
different than plant-based iron it is
copper it's loaded with zinc selenium
and many other trace minerals it has
phosphorus and it also has all of the
essential amino acids and especially
this compound called methionine which
I'll talk about in a minute the two main
common conclusions people have with
eating liver is that they have this idea
that liver is just filled with toxins
well liver itself is not a storage for
toxins it helps you get rid of toxins
but it doesn't hold toxins the fat cells
normally hold toxins but not the liver
and of course the liver that I'm going
to recommend you consume if you can get
a hold of it would be breastfed
grass-finished liver other point about
liver and some people will say well you
don't want to have liver you know very
frequently because you're going to get
an overload and toxicity of vitamin A on
coffee well iron well if you look up the
studies that talk about that they never
talk about consuming excessive Rhythm
okay they talk about consuming uh
individual synthetic vitamins like
synthetic vitamin A or they might talk
about consuming too much copper so of
course liver does not contain synthetic
vitamins now I will say there has been
one study that I could find and that was
consuming
um polar bear liver and that's very
toxic if you consume too much of it
because the amount of vitamin A is a
solid chart but I don't even believe
that you can create a Toxic effect if
you're going to consuming every single
day now of course there's always
exception if you consider them a
tremendous amount of liver potentially
could create a problem but you probably
noticed the side effects and you would
cut that back but here's why the
majority of the population
should start consuming liver because
there's a very common genetic problem
with our population apparently it's a
defect or mutation in a gene called
MTHFR now at first it might look like an
acronym for a dirty word or a swear word
but it's not this Gene if it's altered
in pivots
a certain enzyme that creates a Cascade
of problems in your body in fact this
Gene is probably the most important Gene
in your entire body I'm going to explain
why because if there's a problem with it
you'll have low methylation now what is
methylation methylation involves adding
a methyl group well that's probably
didn't explain anything a methyl group
is
ch3 and methylation is really adding
something to a lot of different enzymes
to create different effects without
manipulation you're not going to be able
to detoxify heavy metals okay and that
includes iron okay so many people have
an issue with too much iron and iron
will build up and then the liver is
affected but with the methylation
problem
you will have a situation where the iron
is not breaking down yet the iron is
unusable to you so you have symptoms of
high iron and symptoms of low iron so
your feet and hands might be cold all
the time despite having a normal thyroid
so that's just one symptom another big
problem is the lack of producing
neurotransmitters so what is that going
to affect that's going to affect your
mood specifically anxiety and depression
another function is DNA repair now is
that important uh yeah especially if you
want to prevent cancer and with this
enzyme problem you'll have a tendency to
be more at risk for a cold intervention
you will also have a problem with
inflammation so let's say you're taking
fish oil turmeric all these things to
get rid of inflammation you're doing
fasting and you still have inflammation
well that's because the cause of it is
this other thing it's a genetic thing
now this enzyme is also involved with
producing energy ATP so you're generally
going to be kind of you're not going to
be able to have the full capacity of
energy despite how many hours of sleep
you get despite how good your diet is it
can also affect your cognitive function
specifically memory focused
concentration so this can lead to Aiden
D it can lead to dementia and even
Alzheimer's methylation also helps you
break down things okay like estradiol to
lesser toxic forms of estrogen so many
people have estrogen dominance in fact
you have too much estrogen you're at
risk for breast cancer and cancer of the
uterus and the ovary and so people will
start taking remedies like you might eat
more cruciferous food or take a product
called dim or avoid soy but they don't
have enough methylation they're not
going to be able to break down the
estrogen as well they might also have
lower testosterone despite how many
things they try to do to fix that
problem methylation also helps to
protect against autoimmune diseases it's
intimately involved with your immune
system and especially to protect you
against the adverse reactions that can
occur when someone gets a vaccine not
being able to methylate increases your
risk of a stroke so I hope you can see
the importance of this whole chemical
pathway well here's the thing you need
to know this chemical pathway is
dependent on two primary nutrients and
some secondary ones too but the two
primary nutrients are folate and b12 so
you even know you are consuming them
from your diet you're just not going to
be able to get enough because they're
not able to be converted to the active
form without this enzyme in methylation
working correctly in fact if you end up
taking the synthetic version of these
two nutrients
which is in all sorts of things which I
will cover that can create a build up
and make things a lot worse because
there's a lot of toxicity symptoms from
just those two nutrients as well if
they're in the synthetic Bond you see
that Gene is all about converting that
nutrient into the active form and so
this is why you never want to take um
like folic acid you want to take folate
which is the natural version and the
same thing with B12 you don't want to
take the
cyanocobolamine version you want to take
the methylcobolamine version now this
specific genetic problem
um is fairly recently discovered because
of the DNA testing that's being done and
the great majority of the population
probably has not tested their genes yet
and so there's a lot of people walking
around with this problem with these
symptoms and don't have a clue of this
connection but it's a very simple
problem to solve if you understand it
and you know do which I'm going to
explain so I recently got a DNA test so
apparently I don't have this exact
problem but I have a version of it which
blocks my ability to use choline as well
as these other two nutrients but not
quite to the degree that someone with
MTH at R would have so in simple terms
what does this mean if you have this
mutation with this Gene it means that
you're always going to be deficient in
the folate and b12 and so the solution
is just to take more of it and it just
so happens out of all the foods that you
can eat
liver is at the top of the list liver
has super mega amounts of folate and b12
and the other Associated nutrients that
go along with methylation and that would
be B2 B3 B6 choline vitamin D zinc and
methionine now let's say for example you
don't like to eat liver well you're just
going to probably have to get a
supplement that has high amounts of the
correct form of B12
B6 and pulling but there are four things
you need to focus on okay number one you
need to take more folate and b12 and
already discussed that and by the way
folate is also in dark green vegetables
but it's also in liver as well all right
number two if you want to avoid the
synthetic folate in B12 that is in the
enrichment process or the fortification
process of various Foods if you consume
the breads the pasta the cereal the
crackers the biscuits you are getting an
enriched grain product with a lot of
synthetic folic acid and b12 so this is
just another reason why you should avoid
grains and when you consume nutritional
yeast many times it's fortified with
synthetic vitamins if you take
nutritional yeast you want to get the
one that's not fortified not enriched
all right number three you want to
minimize your alcohol content no more
than a six-pack a night you don't want
to drink excessive amount because
alcohol tends to make this condition
worse and that probably explains why I
cannot tolerate alcohol I mean if I just
drink a little bit I feel like crap well
it's because of this genetic feedback
now for those of you that don't know
that I have addressed its humor
um I was being sarcastic with the six
pack okay I mean just keep it below like
maybe two or three drinks per night okay
all right number four you might be
taking synthetic vitamins right now and
not even knowing that it's worsening
this problem in fact if you just stop
taking your synthetic vitamins you might
feel so much better and how do I know
the majority of the population is
consuming synthetic vitamins talking
about the folate and the B12 because
99.9 of all vitamins sold on planet
Earth are synthetic so that's how I know
so start reading the labels and hit
vitamins that are from food source or
are from natural sources now since we
did touch on detoxification there's a
really good video that I did on that
that I'd love to share with you and I
put it up right here check it out